the new reality here from the studio
broadcasting this is it you know I I
don't always want to be right but
sometimes I'm right I said that that
music in America would be sooner rather
than later just a large bulbous ass that
would shake then lizzo went and famously
performed in front of a large shaking
ass this is true I said a lot of other
predictions that were right I can't I'm
at I can't think of what they are now
but there was a few of them there was
actually a few of them there was one
that was recent was after the Lizza one
where I predicted it people like [ __ ]
it's exactly what you said oh you said
ah uh eventually the biggest stand up is
going to be someone dancing around on
tik-tok with just like jingles and
jangles like he's not even saying
anything yes that's the biggest stand up
video on tick-tock right right well that
was one of them I said a lot of things I
don't I have a great track record okay
and I said last week I believe that the
only economic activities left will be
what I'm doing right now and the double
penetration seen from requiem for a
dream those are the two options you have
to earn money right now or posts mates
no matter what happens forever there
will be post mates thank God someone
with a mask will hand you a Pokeball
through a door or a slot and they will
scurry away into the darkness forever
and ever no matter if the Yellowstone
supervolcano goes off and ash blocks out
the Sun there will be creatures that
adapt in that environment to glow and
deliver post mates it's just the one
constant we have in America hopefully
we don't know what's going on this is
something that's very interesting
I watched everybody become a conspiracy
theorist over the last two years maybe
even more than that I watched it happen
on the right I watched it happen on the
left I watched normies people that had
never given the Kennedy assassination a
second thought that it never read books
like the Franklin scandal I watched them
go hard into conspiracies
I watched people on the Left go hard
into intrigue espionage trying to figure
out the Russia gate issue I've watched
it and I watched it be done recklessly
sloppily as you would imagine people do
when their minds melt it's what happens
after you spend an entire lifetime in
the mainstream and you're just you know
eaten tomato soup with grilled cheese
and you're just out there trying to go
to college or get your kids into college
where's a fun spot for a vacation
what kind of dog is good with the kids
we have a decent sized yard it's nothing
crazy he'll have some space but you know
how much acting like you go from that
you go from that to Epstein overnight
your mind melts it's true you go from
that to waking up that your leaders are
no good
worse than you thought bad in ways you
can barely comprehend unimaginable
overnight that happens what how can I
get mad at you how can I get mad at
these queueing on people even though
many of them are I believe to be
functionally [ __ ] and I mean you
know unfortunate people how can I get
that mad at them when they're forced to
adapt to to this new world where the
conclusions you come to or show black
pilling so empty that you are forced to
concoct stories in your head about what
is really happening and just like I
watched that I watched people last week
become Preppers I watched people become
n timers over the last week and a half
people that had nothing but positive
things to say are now changing their
tune and I've you know I kid around and
saying that we've been prepared for this
type of thing for a long time but I mean
look this is the set we are the
broadcaster's at the end of the world I
am the anchorman at the end of the world
it's not Ted Koppel it's me it's not the
guy he went on NBC could barely make
sense anymore Tom Brokaw went on NBC he
could barely speak no it's me
I'm the anchorman at the end of the
world that doesn't make me happy it
doesn't please me but it doesn't shock
me either
I'm not surprised by it I'm not
surprised they corrupt oligarchy of
clowns didn't anticipate and/or bungled
the response to a pandemic this is what
happens when you erect a society run by
sociopaths who don't care as Kurt
Vonnegut said they get too
they go maguet to the places they said
to those positions of power because they
don't care what happens next just go do
it do it do that do this do that do that
they don't contemplate they don't sit
back they're not thoughtful
contemplative people they're doers not
thinkers so when you're a doer it all
works until it doesn't you know
Trump is great in boom times he's you
know an 80s political cartoon money's
being made things are good
now it's a little bleak he doesn't look
great he looks like he might have a
touch of Corona we are recording this
Friday everything's changing so much by
the hour yeah then I want to I want to
let you know we're recording this Friday
because I don't know I I heard New York
City was gonna be in quarantine by now
it still may happen we all got that text
from somebody
everybody's got a friend is highly
placed in the government by the way
during the pandemic nobody can get you a
[ __ ] parking pass nobody can help you
at all when it's not a pandemic
now one human being can do anything for
you
they have no they can't get you a
reservation at a restaurant they can't
help you at all but at the end of the
world
everybody's got a highly placed source
in the government that's delivering
terrible news and they want you to hear
first and I heard that they were gonna
quarantine New York City seems like it's
an adventure allottee that certain areas
are gonna get quarantined then you know
BuzzFeed had that thing quoting the NYPD
saying that's all fake it's not gonna
happen there's no plans which great
either get out of it too like there's no
plans at this time at this time is a
great way to say anything you know at
this time no plans to shut down roads
what you little quarantine would be shut
him down the in or out whether they get
people to stay in their house or they
you know I mean after the Boston
Marathon bombing they shut down Boston
he told people to stay in their homes
okay until they caught the terrorists
we're not gonna go into that but that's
you know
now we're thinking about you know Drudge
Report today headline nationwide shut
down being talked about what does that
mean what does that look like how do you
shut down a country of 350 million
people how do you keep all of those
people in their homes there's a lot of
people and a lot of guns I'm not even
saying it's it might not be necessary on
some level you you have to stop the
transmission of this thing you have to
curb the transmission unless we're all
gonna be [ __ ] if you look at Italy you
look at these other countries you know
we're following the same path
they are our healthcare infrastructure
by the way not that much better than
Italy you know I know that but we're
America no we have more people and many
of our systems are as unprepared or
maybe even more unprepared than they're
there you know then there are in other
parts of the world so I wouldn't take
any false confidence don't you know in
the idea that we are a first world
country well we are in some respects and
a lot of respects but you know we're
gonna put that to the test also you know
yeah you know it's also like the of the
conspiracy people going they don't
believe in the virus that doesn't seem
helpful but it is interesting you know I
do understand because their minds have
been melted over the past couple of
years and you're dealing with candle wax
mines you know broken brains um you know
I do understand whose the government's
like well we can't test yeah if you feel
symptoms don't go to the hospital don't
get tested you start going is this
happening is this real are we gonna go
tit [ __ ] the hospital's see a bunch
of nurses playing cards what's the deal
what do you mean don't get tested if you
have symptoms what's that mean we don't
have any [ __ ] tests that's not good
it's a problem